in an interview with nbc news nancy
pelosi was asked whether she thought
trump treats her differently because
she's a woman
me i have no idea i have no idea
we'll see maybe now that how he will
deal with the speaker of the house
and that doesn't matter whether you're a
woman or not but i hope he recognizes
that a new day is drawn in america
so who knows if trump deals with her
differently because she's a lady
the real question is does she treat
trump differently
because he's a man you reportedly
came back spoke to members of your
caucus other democrats and said
the wall it seems like it might be a
manhood thing it might be about his
manhood
that's a statement that's capable of
interpretation care to explain what you
meant
well i wish that my members had not
repeated that outside the room
i bet she does but no matter the real
story is what passes as
news these days you know what the news
is it's a bitter smoothie
made of watered-down old news thrown
into an idiot blender
in this era of good times brought to you
by peace and prosperity
the media must keep making crazy crap up
in the old days
the news went like this something
happened here it is
now it becomes let's ask so and so a
question that gets an opinion that we
can fashion into something that feels
like facts
since we have no new facts regarding the
original story
so you end up with failed opinions that
didn't measure up before
but feels like facts for viewers seeking
validated assumptions because no real
facts exist
so without new stuff on collusion we now
have opinions on collusion
then feelings about collusion then
feelings about opinions on collusion
which suddenly somehow becomes
indictment
everything indicates that a president
can be indicted after he is no longer
president of united what about a sitting
president
well the sitting president when he's no
longer president of the united states a
president who is in office
could robert mueller come back and say i
am seeking i think
that that is an open discussion open
discussion so that's news
the stories we see today are no longer
the four y w's
who what where or why under trump it's
now just one w
repeated over and over again wine wine
wine
you guys want to uh hear what nancy's
daughter had to say about nancy
yeah let's throw all that tape that's
fun she'll cut your head off and you
won't even know you're bleeding
that's all you need to know about her no
one ever won
betting against nancy pelosi you know
i'm gonna do that thing
imagine if ivanka trump was on a show
i said that about donald trump he'll cut
your head off and you won't even know
it's bleeding
that's pretty medieval but they all
laughed cnn all laughed they thought it
was funny oh she decapitated
shoot someone in the middle of new york
and still be elected like something like
that
well that was accurate
facts don't matter anymore we live in an
opinion society where all opinions are
given equal weight even when those
opinions are stupid
and make no sense you know i just
remember when i ran for office arguing
with the washington post guy
uh that the reagan tax cuts had cost the
government money i said here's the
treasury's website the revenue
are you missing this do i have to email
you the link he still refused to debate
and we're seeing it now in the topics
today yeah the wall you know walls don't
work okay there's data on that where
they built the wall
it worked no no it doesn't work okay
well do you are you like in a world
were you vaccinated against facts like
did you at an early age was there some
facts vaccine we all missed vaccinations
same thing about collusion like she
gives an affiliate collusion
well is there any actual evidence of
that are we just going to keep talking
about your opinion on actual collusion i
feel like
i feel like kennedy each story is like
one of those little russian dolls
and we just keep adding another one yes
yeah the nesting goes so collusion then
becomes some somebody says something
then somebody reacts to that
reacts to that and it's just like this
solar system of opinion but
the big question is what's in the middle
right is nougat
creamy nougat god i wish that would be
so fantastic but it is the smallest
nesting doll is that mueller's report
and if so are we ever going to see it
because
now it feels like he's going to hoard
his nesting dolls yes and that's the
threat that we're never really going to
see
uh which one fit inside the other which
then you know nestled inside
the next yes you're absolutely right
about that because the thing is
when you don't have facts and when you
only have a society in discourse that's
based on opinion it's entirely
subjective
and that way you never really get to the
truth and it's interesting because
objectivity and the search for the truth
is now being demonized that is so true
and but but here's the reality and i
admit that it's part of it's part of our
reality jesse
if if trump wasn't around
98 87.3 of our stories would not would
not
exist right yeah it would be about nancy
pelosi it would be about hillary clinton
we go wide for a second this is probably
the scariest thing i've seen all day
let's take oh my god
oh my god we're gonna have to see that
for the next two years
so this is what the media is now doing
we're going to see nancy catapulted up
to the same level
as president trump you're going to see
her face all the time when you see
trump's face it's going to be nancy
and they're going to create this big
collision in the media i don't think
that's a good thing
for democrats nancy pelosi is extremely
unpopular
trump loves contrasting himself with
other people
he loves the fight i think the media is
leading the democrats over the cliff on
this stuff
you just saw her try to get her to play
the gender card savannah
you tried to get her to say oh impeach
impeachment peach
if the media does that to the democratic
party especially nancy pelosi
who's got a pretty fierce left wing
breathing down her neck over the next
two years
gender card race card impeachment
they're going to just drive them over
the cliff
well all of those things existed in the
run-up to the midterms and democrats won
40 seats in the house
with people knowing nancy pelosi would
probably be speakers so people i thought
they campaigned on health care so people
say
yes but she was in every republican ad
jesse you know this as well as i do she
was the foil republicans were running
against
then why did democrats who ran against
her do so well
uh i think the democrats got good
candidates for their districts and 15 of
them did not vote for her today as
speaker including
a number of people who said they would
not so they found candidates that are
not just liberals are not just
progressives like aoc
they fit their districts we have a lot
of moderates she's going to have to
bring them all together together right
and those moderates are going to lose
their seats if they go far left
and so they're not going to so this is
my point to you republicans say she's
this big foil and she's so unpopular and
in some places she is
democrats just want a historic victory
in the house with the the
absolute idea that she would be speaker
so i think people should not
underestimate i underestimated her okay
i said on this program and others she
won't be speaker if we take the house i
was wrong
i underestimated her strength and her
power and it would be stupid of all of
us to keep doing that
all right frankly we must not
historically leave it there i always
like saying that
we must leave it there we'll keep
following it we'll keep following it
that's very good